well it's been a good one so far here in
Boston series finale Red Sox open to
sweep the affair and the Yankees hoping
to salvage one it's birthday time
Jennifer Lopez crashes ESPN's Sunday
Night Baseball with the cake for Alex
Rodriguez's 44th birthday the whole
summer has been at one that I love it's
all he talked about was all the cakes
hey thanks
it's been a family summer has been
awesome there's been a lot of cake this
past week their birthdays are three days
apart my 24 through 27 on Friday night a
rod got another surprise when JLo
brought him on stage during her Miami
concert for more cake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Jennifer turned the big five Oh last
week since we've been together you have
made me feel like every day is my
birthday and Alex recorded this
heartfelt video for his fiancee thank
you for your passion and your energy and
your inspiration and your endless
pursuit to be the best at everything
that you do you're simply the best
partner in life the best daughter of the
best mother the best performer we love
you your fans love you of your children
love you and I love you let's make this
birthday a very special one but it got
me a little emotional I think because of
what he's done and performing on such a
big stage and you know and with the
Yankees all over the United States he he
understands my life in a way that nobody
else really has and and we come from
similar backgrounds and we just we
really have a special connection that
way I think we're very alike in many
ways and I think that's what makes it
work and I think that's why people
respond to the fact that we got together
we're like except I can't sing dance and
I don't look like her besides that when
we complement each other in a beautiful
way and I couldn't have asked for a
better partner in this